チャンスとピンチに対応する知恵
ではどうすればいいかっていうことなんですね
それは宣伝文句ですね
日常日頃から心を磨き澄まして
大切な好機を見逃さないように
チャンスを生かせるようにするためには
どのように心掛けが必要でしょうかと
それでは この点について考えてみましょう
これはもう皆様読まれている文章の一部なんです
最初は日頃から心を磨き澄ますということ
研ぎ澄ます 成功したいと思うなら
欲 怒り 無知 嫉妬 憎しみ
怠け 落ち込み 高慢などの感情ではダメです
成功したいと思うんだったら
欲でやるなよと 怒りでやるなよと
絶対というか ほとんど失敗する
まぐれで成功するかもしれませんだけど
これでやっちゃうと確実に失敗する
例えばイラク戦争でアメリカが勝ったんですかね
まあ見方次第ですけど
もうもう勝ったんじゃないかなという人もいるかもしれませんだけど
でもちょこっと考えてみると
毎日と殺されてるんですけど
戦争の勝利宣言したんだけど
その日からでしょ 人を殺るのを始めたのは
で どれぐらいお金なくなったのかと
それぐらい財産なくしてアメリカは何を得たのかと
だから この怒りで 憎しみで
あれは明らかな無知ですからね
嘘でやった戦争だからね
もううまくいかないんですよ
しかし 人は欲 怒り 競争心などがあるから
希望を立てて努力しているから
なかなか理解してもらわないポイントでもあります
人間はよく私にもよく聞いたことあります
欲がなきゃどうやって商売するんでしょうかとかね
ライバルに対して敵意を持たなかったら
どうやって自分の会社がもう上達するのか
発達するのかどうか やっぱりわからないんですよ
みんな それでは負けますよ
明るくて穏やかで すごく楽しくて
人のことも心配して よく気が利く人ならもう成功するんですよ
例えば会社と会社で商談やっても
相手の会社に対してもすごい慈しみの気持ちを持って
その会社も本当にすくすくと成長して儲かってほしいという気分で話し合っちゃうと
いい相談は成立しますよ
それで次に この成功するためにね
心を研ぎ澄ますために
次に必要なことはこれなんですね
落ち着きとリラックスですね
自我中心的になると 自分が頑固になって波によって壊れてしまうんです
だから固定したものは波に打たれると危ないんですよ
例えば津波が来ると陸上が壊れるんであって
海は壊れませんね 陸上でももうできたものがあったら壊れるんであって
ただの平らだったら何のことなく水が出てきて
また引いていくだけ だから立ち上がっちゃうと波に対して壊れるんです
だから我々世の中で自我ということで
自分がしっかりしてるんだから
もうむちゃくちゃ壊れるんです
だからしっかりするんじゃないんで
その時点では 自我的なしっかりっていうのはとても危ないんです
頑固っていうことだから
自分の世界 世界も因縁により生じる無常たるものだと納得して理解して生きるならば
落ち着くとリラックスが現れるんですよ
ああ 全部変わりますから
まあということで 地震が起きても落ち着いている
いられる 家が壊れても落ち着いていられる
でも あのマンションの人々にはそう簡単じゃないと思いますけど
あれはもうまんまと騙したことだからね
それでも知恵のある人だったらね
まず買わないんですよ
買う前に私ならね とことん調べる
だってずっと証拠あるでしょ
に この建築する人々はみんな手抜きするんだと
みんな欠陥だらけの建物ばっかり作るんだと
で これで日本の建築技術世界一だから
そういう信仰でいるんだから
誰もチェックしない 日本人は正直という
何の根拠もない信仰があるんだから
信仰は危ないんですよ
誰を信仰したっていいの
もうやられてます それでも信仰じゃなくて
人を疑うこともなく 疑うことも気持ち悪いしね
よく具体的に合理的になる
ただそれだけ それだったらもうどういう風に作るのか
どんなどんなものでしょうかとかね
ちゃんと調べてみて うまくいってないで取り消しやと言えばそれで終わりでしょうに
だからそこじゃなくて
そういうマンション買った人々も欲があって
とにかく買ってやるぞ
いいマンションだとかね
あの一番外の皮だけ見て
ああ 結構いいマンションだとかね
これでいいやとか 欲出したところで失敗なんですね
感情が入ったところで
だから まず理性ある人だったら
まずそういう会社からは買わないってことにもなる
買うことになっても とことん調べる
うるさいと言えるほど聞く
聞く 聞く 調べる 毎日毎日行って調べる
向こうはうるさいって言ったら怒る
あんた方はそんなこと言ったってお金払うのはこちらだからと言って
こちら一生一代のことだからと
冗談じゃないぞと そういう調度でいけば
まああまり問題は起きません
しかし それでも問題が起きたならば
やっぱり世の中はみんな信頼するものじゃない
泥棒はいっぱいいるんだよということで
まあ泥棒にやられたということで
まあ一応損は損ですけど
落ち着いていられる それによって世の波にどのように対応するべきかと見えてくるんです
それで見えてくるんですよ
この波だったらこうするんだよと
わかりやすく言えば あまり私はわかりやすく言ったっても
かえってわかりにくくなりますけどね
できるだけ一般日本語で書いてみようかなと思ったんです
私は神様ではないから
どうなるかわかりませんと
世の中は無理を強引 無理に強引に物事を変えるのも正しくないし
何もしないで待つよりは何かをした方が良いのではないんですかと
結果は私が知ったことではないが
必要と思う行動だけをするという生き方になるんです
私は特定の人間ではない
世の中の波 海の一滴だから
次どうなるかと 私 私に聞いたってもね
例えばあなた商売してるでしょ？だから来年本当にこんなこと聞いてもわかりませんよと
世の中のことだから 神様じゃないんだよと
しかし 何もしないで馬鹿みたいに待ってる
意味がないんだから まあそれなりにね
行動はしているんだよと
結果は結果は私が決めるものじゃなくて
波によって現れるものであると
そうなるとかなり頭がすごい明確になるんです
という気分ですね わかりやすく言えば簡単で
私は神様じゃないと 本当はみんな自分が神様という気分で生きているんですよ
で ちょこっと文脈は変わります
タイトル変わると同時に
ものすごい内容も変わりますけどね
人生は樹海の旅です 何ができるのかわかりませんが
大体は見当がつく 樹海の中で歩くと何が起こるかわからないでしょう
しかし 大体は見当がつくでしょ
獣もいるし 崖もあるし
美しいものも果物もあって
毒の植物も木々もあるでしょうね
周りはほとんど似ていて
どこを行くべきか理解できませんでしょ
樹海にいると だから本格的に人生は樹海の旅だと思ってください
それは事実です どこへ行ったって同じですよ
樹海の中は だから東に行こうか
西に行こうか 後ろの全然どうでもいいことで
しかし 危険はいっぱいあるのです
大体見当つきます 危険ばっかりでもないんですよ
花も咲いているし 綺麗な水もあるし
見れる果物も食べるものもあるかもしれませんし
周りに常に注意して気づいて歩むんです
樹海の中は一歩ずつ注意しないと
ヘビでもいたらどうしますかね
これが人生なんです 一歩ずつ注意して歩かなきゃいけないんです
これしかやることありませんよ
すごい難しくないんですよ
樹海の中でも一歩ずつ注意して
どこを歩いたっていいんです
どうせ逃げられるくはないし
樹海に迷子になった旅人
旅人はところで樹海に迷子になって旅をする
この旅っていうのは何なのかというと
飲める水はどこ？食べられる果物はどことかね
獲物はどこなどでしょう
で 私たちも同じことでしょうね
それしか気にしてないんです
何かいいことないのかとか
何か金儲かる方法ないのかとか
何かよりいっぱい仕事できる方法ないのかとかね
クマトラの住処はどこ？と気にする人もいる
それあまり少ないんですよ
我々もこの成功する成功するばっかりで考えているんだけど
世の中危ないことももうほとんどたくさんですけど
それも気にしてほしいんですけど
みんな食べるものはどこだけの話で生きているでしょうね
でも少ない人々は まあ樹海にいる旅人は
クマはどこにいるか 虎はどこに住んでいるのかとかね
そういうところも気をつけるんですよ
そうするとより安全なんです
食べ物ばっかり森の中で探していると
もう熊にやられる可能性はあります
だから食べ物も探しながら
熊にも注意という必要はあります
世俗世間で考えるチャンスとピンチはこのようなものです
食べ物に尽きたらあ チャンスで
熊に遭遇したらピンチでという
人生の中でもうまくいけばチャンスで
うまくいかなかったらピンチだというんですね
成功ばかりをして幸福に生きるためには
次に成功ばかりして幸福に生きる方法はないんですか？あります
これが興味はゼロですと
なんかちょっとおかしい
で 次のこと忘れ間違ったかな
えーと 我々はよく考えているのは成功
まあそういうことなんですけど
人間にとってはそれ以外は興味がないんですよ
この樹海の中でとにかくどうやって成功するのかというね
いわゆるどうやって食べ物に尽くなのかというぐらいのことで
うん それでその樹海の話を仏教に合わせてみます
な 樹海に迷子になった人の注意は少々命を延ばすだけで解決ではありません
そこで樹海の中でうまく生きていても
ただ早く死ななかっただけ
クマが行くとこに行かなかったと
毒キノコは食べなかったと
夜寝る時は洞窟に寝るんじゃなくて
木の上で寝たんだぐらいのことで
木の上でやっても蛇が来て噛まれる可能性もあるし
うまくいったら一応長生きぐらいができるだけのことで
我々の人生もそういうもんなんですよ
人生うまくいったらちょこっと長生きできるだけ
これ解決じゃない 周りに完全に注意しながら
樹海を出ることに励むことが解決なんですよ
だからとにかく樹海ではダメや
これではいくら頑張ってももう不安だよと
樹海を出なくちゃいけないんですね
出て 人間が住んでいる村に入らなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうすると 本当にああ
よかった 枕高くして寝られるということになるんですよ
それで完全に危険から恐怖から身を守ったことになる
だから樹海っていうのは存在であって
輪廻であって生き方なんです
これから脱出することこそが答えなんです
天国に生まれるとか 冗談な話です
樹海の中だからね 樹海の旅人よりは
樹海を出ることに挑戦する人は最大の成果を収める
これ具体的に考えてください
二人がいる 一人が樹海は危ないと思って
いかに身を守ることをか
それだけしか考えない
もう一人は やっぱりこの樹海から逃げなくちゃいけないんだと
樹海は危ないんだと それでその人も歩む
大丈夫 一向方向へすーっと歩けば
やがて 出ます それで 2番目の人も
樹海は危険だから 樹海の中に歩いているんだから
クマの気をつけるわ 毒キノコも気をつけるわ
蛇にも気をつけるわ 夜寝る時も気をつけて寝る
だからお互い様同じですよ
実は成功している しかし
2番目の人は人生も成功しながら最大の成功も収める
樹海から出たと だから解脱の道を歩むことは
何一つも損する道じゃないんです
対応の仕方 計画 希望などがあっても
それにこだわっ こだわったりすることで状況が見えなくなる
いろんな計画があって
計画だけにこだわっちゃうと
計画を実行できる状況が見えなくなるんですよ
それ樹海の中で夜寝ていてもクマが
現れたら逃げる時間ないでしょうに
今寝る時間だから明日クマ追い払うとはなりませんね
樹海に行けてるんだから
それで計画あるんですよ
夜は寝るというね 歩けませんと
樹海の中に そんな計画があっても
環境に気づいておかないと
そこでクマが現れちゃうと
あの計画は一旦中止しなくちゃいけない
クマから身を守らなくちゃいけない
それで危なくて ずっと朝まで寝ることはできなかったってこともありますよ
これは生きる 오히려しょうがないんです
計画はあってもきれいさっぱり計画中止ということになります
だから計画あるのはいいんだけど
環境に気づいてほしいんです
いつでも計画を変える
変えられるような状態でいなくちゃいけないんです
ということは 成功の秘訣は計画よりも今現在の状況に気づくことなんです
成功の秘訣はこれなんです
これで結論なんです 過去と現在のことをごちゃごちゃ考えるんじゃなくて
今の状況に気づいておくんです
ブッダの世界ではとことんサティとか気づきとかね
ずっと教えているのはその真理なんです
いかなる計画であろうとも
状況に合わせて瞬時にたちまち改良変更できる柔軟性です
だから 決して希望に計画に願望
こだわるんじゃない 悪くないんだけど
うまくいけばいいんじゃないかってぐらいの調子
でも挑戦するぞと 挑戦するんだけど
状況変わったらすぐ変わっちゃうということで
女性の例で言えばね 白馬に乗った王子様が来るのは期待したってもいいんだけど
そこら辺の男の子を話しかけたら
そいつと結婚した方がいいんです
それって曖昧な生き方ではないかとね
曖昧かしっかりするかっていうこと
曖昧で優柔不断で見えるが
実は反対ですよ あなた計画はあっても偉そうにすぐ変わったでしょうとかね
人に言われるかもしれませんよ
なんで自分の希望にもう一心に粘り強く頑張らないんでしょうかとかね
この人はとにかく成功しますよ
しかし これがポイントなんです
曖昧で曖昧に見えたっても成功するんだからね
間違えた 理性があって
判断能力が早い 常に状況を観察するから
理解能力と経験が積み重ねていくんですよ
だって今の瞬間に気づいてるでしょうに
だから常に状況判断できるんですよ
だから頭も良くなって
経験もどんどんどんどん積み重ねていくんです
世界の波に衝突して壊れることはない
波が来るときれいにそこに合わせちゃいますからね
壊れません あるいはもう一つポイントがあります
そうやって曖昧よりはしっかりした方がいいんじゃないかなって気分もあるでしょうね
条件に合わせて調整しながら生きることは悪くはないが
どこかにこの優柔 何でしたっけ？柔軟性
柔軟性は曖昧で見えるんですよ
私はこの柔軟性は謳ったんだけど
なんかちょこっと曖昧に見えるんですよ
頑固で目的に真っ向から挑戦する人々のことも羨ましく見えることもある
社会から誤解される 批判される可能性もある
会社でもそんな人をね
ちょっと非難することもありますよ
正しい生き方なんですけど
本人は成功するし 攻撃を受けないし
うまくいってるんだけど
いろいろ言われますよ
それにも解決してもらわないと仏教じゃないんです
だったら これ解決法なんですよ
希望は頂点を目指すことにするんです
そうすると曖昧でなくなっちゃいます
そんなちょこっとの希望じゃなくて
とにかく頂点目指すぞと
であるならば 複数のごちゃごちゃの一時的な希望
願望ではなく 最高のこれ最小の
優れたっていう感じで来てきたの
頂点の希望 願望を立てるんです
ではどうですか？と よく言われるのは
あんたもう勉強しようと理科系やろうと思ったんだけど
ちょっと嫌だからやめたでしょ
そんな人生では そんな話ですよ
本人が理科やってやろうと思ったってうまくいかないんだから
じゃあ音楽にするとしただけで
それ成功するんだったらいいでしょうに
それで世界はね あんた悠々不断でどうしようもないんだと
そう言われないためには何するのかというと
最高のトップの希望を作っていくんです
この上はないという そこを目指すんです
樹海のたとえなら 樹海を出ること
樹海でどう生きることじゃなくて
トップな目的はそれなんです
人生なら完全たる人格者になること
悟ることを解脱することなんです
だから樹海は人生に例えたんだから
人生なら解脱すること
悟ることが 私はそれを目指しているんだぞと
商売繁盛じゃないんだよと
他全ての希望は二次的であってもなくても気にすることはありません
そうなっちゃうと全然波にやられません
まあ私はあれを目指しているんだからね
例えばヒマラヤ登る時でももう命懸けでしょ
環境はもう瞬時に環境が変わるし
恐ろしいでしょうし 風とかね
テントなんかはもう全く倒れるな
倒れたりもするし 倒れてそれで死んじゃうでしょう
しかし そういう人々は何のことなくへっちゃらでいるんです
あのテレビで最近見た番組で
この激しくこの風が吹いちゃって
みんな寝ることも何もできなくて
ずーっと何時間もテントを待ち構えて捕まってるんですよ
こうやって ひどい頃ですけど
並の寒さじゃないでしょうに
でも別なすごい目的があるんだからね
こんなのは全然気にしないということになるんです
それで波に打たれない人間になるんですよ
だから希望を作るんですよ
頂点の希望 まあそろそろ終わります
で 頂点を目指す その場合は日常生活でも失敗しない
まあいいわ 複層の希望で願望で悩むこともない
いろんな希望があって
願望があれもやりたい
これね それはもう消えちゃいます
そんな二次的だからね
で 最大の目的に達するように
二次的な希望 願望を適切に前提する
だから私は前言った この切り捨ててくださいということは自動的になるんです
これは私は目指している目的には関係ないんだぞと
自動的に全部切り捨ててたんです
それでしっかりした必要な希望で止まるんです
今の瞬間の判断 行動という場合も心配することはないんですよ
判断する基準があるから瞬時に判断ができる
これってよくちょっと考えてほしいんですよ
私もよく言うでしょ 今の瞬間に判断しなさいと
すぐたちまち そういうことを言っても
我々にその能力ないんですよ
例えば 子供はすごい何か悪いことをして興奮したところで
私よく言うのは その瞬間で冷静に判断して答えて
そんなこと言ったって
親がすぐカッとなって怒っちゃうんですよ
怒って怒鳴ったりする
それで結果として悪くなっちゃうでしょうね
それで親が言うのは そんなこと言われても瞬時に判断できんよということなんですよ
実際そうなんですよ 瞬時に判断できる人っていうのは
なかなか世の中でないんですよ
これはもう賢者にしかできない仕事なんです
妄想で悩んでる人にはできない
しかし 解脱するぞと希望をきちっと定めておいてください
能力ついてきます だって基準があるでしょうに
これは心清らかにするために
役に立つんですよ 役に立たないな
例えば子供が悪いことしたところで
割ったことは悪いんだけど
叱責しなくちゃいけないんだけど
私が怒ったら私汚れるでしょうと
これは解脱には逆効果だと思った瞬間に怒らなくなっちゃうんです
それで ああそう なんでそんなことやったの？とかね
聞けます 面白かった？かっこよかったですか？とかね
かっこ悪いんじゃないの？とかね
そういう話することはできますよ
それと子供もよく理解できる親だなとかね
思ってよくおとなしくなります
だから解脱というすごい目的があると
瞬時の判断する あの能力研ぎ澄ますことっていうのはすぐ現れるんです
俗世間の希望を乗り越えた成功をせぬ
で それで終わりません
俗世間では考えられないのように成功するんです
たとえ解脱しようと目的の人が商人であっても
誰よりも生涯の成功するんですよ
例えば ある学者がいて
自分が学問よりは解脱したいと決まって
それ目指して頑張っていると
学業も見事に成功するんです
仏教学の世界ではいろいろ論文を読んでみると
この真面目に仏道すごいと
これこそあゆみ道べきやという納得している先生たちの論文というのは
ものすごい立派なんです
ほとんど見事に情報を集めて書くんですよ
いい加減なもうものと書かない
ということで 大体この成功します
どちらでも 絶好の機会って何や
ということで しかし 刀入れているのは一応もうちょっとケチつけるという意味なんです
仏教の思考によると 絶好の機会も
これは強引に作った単語なんですけど
だから読めないんです
で 機会も成り立たない概念です
そんなのはありえないんです
俗世間的な希望 願望の基準がある人に考えられる概念ですよ
俗世間的で ちっちゃなちっちゃな希望で悩んでいる人々にとっては
まあ絶好の機会とかあるかもしれませんだけど
仏道ではそんなことは全然ないんです
最高の最小の最優のかな
希望がある人に いかなる条件でも乗り越えるか使用するかですよ
だからこれ仏道の道なんですよ
最高の希望を作るんです
解脱するんだと そうするともう呪戒の例えで言えば
いかに使用するかという
この環境は文句言わない
ちょっと崖で滑ったとしたら
あ よかった 早く行っちゃったと
行きたい方向に文句言わない
だから仏教から見れば
チャンスもピンチもすべて絶好の機会
絶好の機会ですよ 人格向上を目指す人には
いかなる条件でも自分を磨くための最高のチャンスです
すべて絶好ですよ 皆が悪いから良い人間になれないと他人のせいにすることはないんです
みんな悟ってないんだから
私は悟るわけないでしょうとか
みんなが悪いからこそ自分が良い人間になるのだと
その機会 チャンスを生かすんです
それ仏教的なやり方なんです
みんなやってるいいこと
じゃあ私もやると それも使う
誰もやってない では私がやりますと
どっちだけでもいいんです
その人にとっては 良い環境も悪い環境も励みになるんです
だから それは仏道だけに限った話です
危険もない それで危険もない道ですよ
闇雲に踏ん張ると危険ばかり
悪結果ばかりですが 心の汚れを落とす希望の場合は
必死で努力しても結果は必ず善なんです
失敗はありません だから高い希望を作っちゃうと
心清らかにする希望でしょうに
別に踏ん張っても悪結果ないんですよ
欲の希望だったら闇雲になっちゃうとどうなるかわからないんですよ
だから世の中の希望っていうのはものすごい危険の方がものすごいんです
仏教的な希望を作っちゃうと危険ゼロになっちゃう
だから別に闇雲に頑張っても大丈夫なんです
自分も幸福で 周りにも幸福を与える生き方をしているんです
その人は 仏教的に見ると
常にあるのは絶好の機会です
ブッダの言葉はチャンスとピンチの話ではなく
機会の話です だから全部絶好
だから絶好と言う必要もないんです
だからブッダは絶好とも取っちゃって
機会という単語を使うんです
よくある言葉で カナンゴーマーウパッチャガーというね
機会を失うなかれと 二度とない機会を失ってはならないんです
瞬間瞬間状況変わるでしょうに
それそれを機会 絶好ですよ
だから失ってはならないと
今日は状況悪いんだから明日から頑張るぞってことはないんです
どんな状況も絶好な機会です
そういう機会を失わないということ
機会は絶好でも悪でもありません
自分の対応によって最悪になったり
絶好になったりするんです
ただの機会ですよ だからブッダは機会という単語を使ってますよ
それは絶好か最悪かというのは人の対応なんですよ
ミスったら最悪で うまくいったら絶好で
だからミスってはいけないというブッダの言葉なんです
今絶好のチャンスだと飛びかかる人は正しくない
よくあ 今だと言って飛びかかって
それからもう待ちましょうというね
そういう即席の生き方はあまり正しくないんですよ
自分の 対応さえ良ければ
あるのは絶好のチャンスのみです
例えば商売をやっている人は
その商売は不景気でうまくいかない場合は
その時はそのテクニック
ノウハウを使って別なことをやらなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると全然損はしないんです
頑固な人はやらないんですね
私はこういう商売だからということで
どう対応するというね
あ ちょっと待った 間違った
今の瞬間をよく理解する
瞬間のことだから 推測することはできる
この対応の仕方 チャンスに
機会に 今の瞬間だけ考えればいいんです
そうしちゃうと小さいでしょ
推測することができるんですよ
あ 今はこういう状態なのかなのかと
時間を長くして 例えば 1年など見ると全然わからなくなるんですよ
来年は経済状況はどうなるのかというとわからないでしょうに
今日はどうですか？と言えば見事にわかるでしょう
だから この今の瞬間を理解する
そうすると今の瞬間でこう対応すると
次の瞬間でこう対応すると
だからいつでも推測して対応しているんですよ
間違えるはずがないんです
で 時間延ばしちゃうと単なる推測ですよ
推測は当たったり当たらなかったりでしょうに
で ここで結論ですよ 今は気にするべきなのは
人は気にするべきなのは
今どうすれば良いか それだけ
今日はそれだけでも覚えておいてください
我々は今どうすれば良いか
それだけで生きていられます
すごい元気に生きていられます
失敗ゼロで 明日明後日ではなくて
今どうすればよいですか？と
時々悩んだりするでしょうに
その時 今どうすれば 今やることないんだぞとわかったら悩み事はなくなっちゃうんです
これですよ 言いたいのは
そこまで喋って 何を隠そうまだあるんです
続きは ちょこっとこういうのやらないと
真理の世界をね ちょっと覗いてみないと
これ言わなかったら私が納得しないんです
なぜならば 講演は私の立場から見れば不完全なんです
一切というのは存在ですね
無常です 読むだけで十分だと思います
自分他の瞬間しかない現象です
この世の中も自分も瞬間だけの現象ですよ
何一つとも永久的に二度と現れません
すべて永久的に二度と現れません
すべては一回きりの現象です
すべて自分も他も 計画を立てたり
期待をしたりしても それは無意味です
成り立ちません 本当は
例なんですけど 明日美味しいご飯を食べたいと思う
明日いいものを食べようかなと
しかし 明日美味しいご飯を食べるのは別な人で別なご飯です
昨日イメージしたものではありません
でしょ だから計画を立てても
結局はそれは実行したのは別の人なんです
それでそれをこともまた別なものなんです
それは無常の世界の本当の状況なんです
今の瞬間は永遠に永久的に再現しない
よく覚えておいてください
今の瞬間というのは永久的に再現はなし
似てる現象があっても同じものではありません
何一つも だから結論 何一つも執着することに悩んだり
期待したりすることに値しない
あって一生一回の瞬間だから
別にこれ大事やと思ったって
すぐに別な瞬間でしょうに
だから無常から成り立つのは
何一つも執着するに値しないということ
答えなんです 心は完全に無執着に
無執着になった方が最高の平安です
だったら こんな次から次へと現れてくる消えていく現象
自分も次から次へと消えていくんですよ
何にも執着しないで それが最高の平安と呼んでいる
これは希望はゼロ状態です
最初に言ったんです  ２つあるんだと
ある程度希望を叶ってもらって乗り越える世界です
同時に一切の希望が叶った状態でもあります
例えば樹海に例えてみれば
樹海をずっと歩く時でも
元気で熊を避けて歩いてきたんだから成功でしょうね
それで樹海を出たところで
もう成功でしょうね すべて希望叶っているんです
すべて希望叶ったんだから
もうゼロです 最高勝利を得たことでもある
希望はありませんとは
希望を計画を立てるぐらいの元気も失った
激しい妄想に潰された人とは正反対です
あの希望ない人はいくらでもいるでしょ
世の中で あれはただ妄想で潰されてるだけ
もう人間じゃないんです
それとはこれが違います
これは頂点に達したんだからね
希望がないだけに 仏教は希望はゼロに挑戦するんです
かなりの道なんです で
それで話は終わると思います
じゃあどうもありがとうございます